[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Melanie
is with us in Philadelphia hi Melanie
welcome to the ramsy
show hi so excited to be here thank you
for taking my call we're honored how can
we help um first of all let me just say
George I'm reading your book is super
awesome oh thank you so much appreciate
that yeah no problem so my my question
is so my husband and I are in baby step
two um I'm working two full-time jobs
he's a school teacher and also has a
training like a personal training um gig
on the side that he does he rents his
own facility um but he's had it for four
years and my concern is that he really
hasn't made any profit off of the
business he makes just enough to just
pay the bills at in the business um at
what point do I have that conversation
that it may not be worth his
time um in the business just because
it's just not bringing
then anything that doesn't make money is
called a
hobby right it's not a side hustle it's
a
hobby he likes work he likes personal
training so much he's willing to do it
for
free almost I mean he makes some money
but not as much as I think he should
because he's been doing it for you're
changing your tune in the middle of the
call which is
it how much does he really make net
profit on the thing
probably it varies every month so we can
run range anywhere from, 1500 to like
2500 a month
profit oh well you said after he pays
his bills he's not making much if
anything he's not bills has he got the
rental on this
place yeah just the rental on the place
and then you know he has like um that
his utilities are included with the rent
in the facility and then he has like I
know his internet or something that he
pays okay okay so he's getting 1,500 to
2500 in what's the
rent uh
1,600 so it almost takes everything so
if he doesn't make 1,600 in a month he
loses
money right
okay well I I I don't think it's
unreasonable to sit down tonight and say
Honey I we've got to look at this as a
business and and we need to look and see
what we've got to do with your pricing
and the number of clients that you have
to make what you're doing over there
profitable mhm because it's not okay
that you're spending all this time over
there and potentially even losing
money right so let's get let's get out
the numbers let's get out the numbers
and run a p&l on this thing and just
just sit there tonight and run a
spreadsheet on it how long's he been
doing it um he's had this place now for
four years okay well let's go back La
you know for the last 12 months pull
pull the revenue and then put in600 a
month then put in the internet fee a
month and and let's see if we've really
got a profit or not figure out what is
hourly wages on this my
guess you know you made 500 bucks and
you spent 600 hours over there right
you're making a dollar an hour come on
man you know as a business owner how do
you like at what point do you say like
it's just not viable anymore how much
time he's supposed to be like an adult
and stuff he teaches children yeah yeah
he does what does he
teach uh health and fad okay and how how
what what age
children uh anywhere from kindergarten
to high school okay and so we would
assume that they know how to do basic
addition of
subtraction yes and he
should if he's teaching them I mean
really
I we he needs you know you need to sit
down with him and say I I need you to
look at this Through The Eyes of a
business and let's look at it for a few
minutes and let's see if you think this
is
worthwhile but I don't you don't need to
tell him he needs to he ought to be able
to a logical adult male female should be
able come to a conclusion on this
without his wife or husband telling them
I mean you ought to be able look at it
and go I'm making a dollar hour no that
doesn't cut it you
know I'm supposed to be providing for my
family during this time no no and you
guys are in debt and so I think that's a
part of this equation is we need to
actually make money right now so here's
the thing anytime we're in a business
situation with our entree leadership
clients on a side hustle or a small
business idea we do one of a couple
things one is we have to ask ourselves
what can we change to make this
viable and if the answer is there's not
a change that'll make it viable then
it's time to shut it
down okay I mean I think you guys are
going to look at this and figure out I
think you're going to look at this
figure out you put $188,000 or what is
it $199,000 in rent into it last year
mhm you know and he brought in 19,500
bucks I think that's what you're going
to find yeah I think so too and and you
know so and then how many hours you
spent over there divide that into 500
and you look at him go honey what part
of this is smart none right right so you
know
you so we something has to
change this is not okay we have to raise
our prices increase the number of
clients both or we got to say we're not
doing this
anymore okay yep gonna have that
conversation I appreciate your your
opinion on that I guess the other thing
is you know do you have a
basement we do why don't you do it down
there yeah 1,600 bucks ahead per month
instantly another thing people do now is
they'll go to your house and do the
workout there oh yeah
yeah and the other thing they can he can
do is just go work at a gym that already
has personal training and they hire him
and pay him money so he doesn't have any
of the overhead yeah so there's a lot of
options part of the equation on the
business model may be getting rid of
this rent and suddenly yeah you're
you're doing in home work and in your
home work in in other people's homes for
them you know personal training you go
visit Jim then you go visit George and
then you do whatever I mean that's the
dream and they pay you money you know
and um I have a gym in my house we did
that for a long time and so um my wife
made fun of me she said you know the
guy's counting for you you can't count
to 10 you're pay you need in that moment
paying that guy a big money for counting
no I'm paying him for
accountability there's that but I I I
can count to 10 I already can do one two
I can I can count you need a guy yelling
at you other than the guy in your head
we don't need anybody yelling at me but
um but we need someone just I know if
he's going to come over there then I'm
going to do the workout right otherwise
I might find my little butt on the sofa
you know that could happen and so that's
that's what you know that's what a
personal trainer does sometimes we know
what we can Google the workout we hire
the personal trainer because we need
that level of handholding right now yeah
I mean that's okay yeah so I mean do it
he could he could provide the service
like George is saying charge even more
to come to people's homes in person um
and or in your basement and or if you're
going to keep the location you got to
make the
location having the location needs to
cause you to make more money than not
having the location would cause you to
make I think you're going to get rid of
this location at a minimum create your
free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life